depuis le 20 avril 68 2 millions
d'égyptiens sont appelés aux urnes
ils ont trois jours pour voter pour ou
contre une modification de la
constitution
[Musique]
en fait au-delà de ça il vote surtout
pour donner la possibilité abdel fattah
al-sisi de prolonger sa présidence si le
oui l'emporté cela implique plusieurs
choses d'abord le mandat actuel de 6,6
passerait de 4 à 6 ans et se terminerait
donc en 2024
ensuite le nombre limite de mandats
passerait de 2 à 3 ce qui permettrait à
l'ancien ministre sous moubarak de se
présenter une troisième fois et donc de
rester au pouvoir jusqu'en 2030
[Musique]
un autre changement inquiétant concerne
l'indépendance de la justice
depuis 2010 est le président nomme le
président du conseil d'état et de la
cour de cassation et si la réforme passe
il nommera en plus le dirigeant de la
cour constitutionnelle et le procureur
de la cour suprême
autrement dit tous les organes
judiciaires du pays seraient dirigées
par des proches d'elle fattah al sisi
[Musique]
en finir cette révision de la
constitution affirmerez le rôle
politique de l'armée elle deviendrait
officiellement la garante de la
démocratie et de la constitution
l'enjeu de ce scrutin est donc
considérable et pourtant il n'ya presque
aucun suspens au parlement seuls 22
députés sur 596 ont voté contre ou se
sont abstenus et la quasi totalité des
médias relais un discours procès si et
diabolisent les opposants à cette
réforme
la faute à une répression féroce du
régime une répression que si si et ce
soutien justifie par la lutte
antiterroriste alors oui c'est vrai
d'egypte qui doit faire face à un réel
danger dans le sinaï surtout où le
groupe est islamique est encore
implantés mais cet argument est souvent
utilisé par al sisi pour justifier ces
positions qualifiées d' autoritaire par
l'opposition et la grande majorité des
ong
il a notamment contraint ses opposants
en majorité des islamistes était laïque
de gauche à l'exil il en a condamné
d'autre à de lourdes peines de prison et
a restreint la liberté d'expression sur
internet pour faire taire les dernières
avant critique
en janvier dernier le ng amnesty
international avait qualifié l'egypte de
prison à ciel ouvert pour les dissidents
politiques crime
[Musique]